[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
happy Friday I am cat Tim I'm in for
Greg who's a little under the weather
tonight and I cannot emphasize this
enough the coffee I got him yesterday
was not poison
shout out to my lawyers for reminding me
to say that on the air
all right uh let's welcome tonight's
guests she's so libertarian she's
neutral in the war on Christmas host of
Kennedy on Fox Business it's Kennedy
[Applause]
she breaks more Southern stereotypes
than a well-mannered hog Fox Business
anchor Dagan McDowell
he's a stand-up comedian by day and a
hot sexy Gigolo by Night comedian Joe
Mackey
and his clothes are like the
Constitution passed down by dead people
founder of the loftusparty.com and
author of the book neither stunning nor
Brave Michael Loftus
so before we get to some news stories it
is Friday so it's time for
Greg's leftovers
time once again for leftovers it's where
Greg reads the jokes we didn't use this
week and I know he wouldn't want them to
go to waste so I'm gonna give it a go
like Greg this is my first time reading
these so if it's bad it's not my fault
here we go
New York city mayor Eric Adams wants to
hire a rat Czar to rid the city of
rodents but it may be too late
considering 90 percent of them have
already moved to Florida
huh
California governor Gavin Newsom told
Politico he won't run for president in
2024 no matter what Joe Biden does so
you heard it here first even if Joe
Biden nukes Canada Gavin Newsom won't
run
Newsom later added that the main reason
he won't run is that Biden already has
enough to deal with
it's a poop joke
speaking of California the state has
reportedly released thousands of
convicted pedophiles after they spent
just months in jail
California where gas costs six bucks and
pedophiles are free
[Laughter]
this week President Biden said to a room
full of reporters quote 10 years ago how
many of you even knew what a supply
chain was replied one reporter that's
only because we didn't know your son
Hunter
in an interview former FTX CEO Sam
bankman freed claims he committed no
fraud and his defense where Sam grew up
fraud means sex
for the holidays Pizza Hut has announced
the return of their triple treat box
which contains two medium one-topping
pizzas five breadsticks and 10 Cinnabon
mini rolls and if you call now they'll
throw in a free heart attack
all over the country seems like
everyone's getting into the Christmas
spirit for instance here in Manhattan
cops have switched to outlining bodies
with tinsel
in a new interview Will Smith said he
understands if people aren't ready to
see his new film following the Oscar
slap which doctors say is a good
attitude to have because worrying will
only make your hair fall out
new Disney CEO Bob Iger admitted this
week that the company screwed up he told
employees that he wants to quiet down
the culture wars he said he hopes to
return to a simpler time when it was
easy to hide in the background of The
Little Mermaid
last week a Georgia woman gave birth to
a baby girl and an Atlanta McDonald's
some of the workers were so moved they
actually took the time to wash their
hands
you know
finally the World Health Organization
announced that they're changing the name
of monkey pox to empox to eliminate
stigmatizing language they'll also be
changing the name of covid too don't
worry it's just allergies
all right now some actual news they're
raising the alarm about China's
propaganda arm according to Forbes the
Communist Chinese government has been
operating Tick-Tock accounts to
influence American politics and attack
Republican officials
this of course is on top of a diabolical
years-long campaign to punish American
diners with a mustard hot enough to make
your nosebleed
Washington dc-based foreign agent called
media links TV posted videos on Tick
Tock in the run-up to the midterm
elections with captions disparaging
Republican candidates
that's something that's traditionally
been the sole responsibility of CNN
MSNBC CBS and ABC
but the post never clearly disclosed
they were coming from the Chinese
government Tick Tock itself of course is
owned by a Chinese company and many have
accused the social media app of spying
on Americans on behalf of China's
Communist Party
if I want to be spied on I'll do what
most Americans do stay at an Airbnb
so now I will discuss with my panel and
solve this complex geopolitical issue in
just five minutes
all right digging why do you think
they're going after Republicans
specifically
oh I think you're going after everybody
though and it's not just it's not do you
think that Chinese propaganda is just
relegated to Tick-Tock like some
blubbery dangerous free homebody with
three guinea pigs and the gout and some
hot chick like is hitting him up on his
DMS on Instagram yeah that's not Chinese
propaganda
um I but I stay off Tick Tock I have no
room at the end my brain is full I avoid
teenagers in real life so I'm not going
on Tech talk
um I have all the makeup tips I need I
look like a man as it is
um
I I don't I don't have enough and I do
not have enough friends to learn a group
dance
I already I remember the Boot Scootin
Boogie from the early 90s so I'm good so
I'm not on Tick Tock Kennedy you are
unable to avoid teenagers in real life
yeah
two of them in your house all the time
are they on Tick Tock they're on Tick
Tock constantly okay so it's it's really
funny because I was thinking about this
the reason that they're disparaging
Republicans is because younger people
are on Tick Tock and they hate
Republicans because they've never paid
taxes right so all Democrats are doing
is promising them free crap so they
think that Democrats are really really
great uh when they finally start paying
taxes they probably won't be disparaging
Republicans as much but it's not just
the Chinese who are spying on us the
post office is literally there's a story
earlier in the year the post office is
spying on us and every single social
media site you could imagine so I was
thinking about this uh Elon Musk has
inserted himself into the social media
discussion by buying Twitter so I was
thinking like maybe he could do the same
thing with Tick Tock I think Elon Musk
yeah
yeah I that's such a that's such a great
idea I hope he's I'm sure he's watching
I know he's a big fan of the show big
fan big fan Mackie
you have Tick Tock dances is that what
you're doing with your time well first
off cat I look like a man and I just
like
I just like to say that whenever I have
an opportunity
[Music]
uh but my my dance videos aren't on Tick
Tock but that's a brilliant idea because
if I put my dance videos on Tick Tock
I'll seduce the spies that's right and
they they won't have a chance to crack
down on the distance with apple that's
true you know what okay I think the only
thing that's missing from this
conversation about complex geopolitics
is what does Michael Loftus thing
I'm slow I just got to tick tock and I
love it it is the crack cocaine of
social apps but there's two of them
there's like the Chinese version and
then there's the the American version
yeah which makes seriously the whole
thing is like in and out there's a
secret one and I guess like in China
they're all watching like you know how
to do kung fu and math problems and
stuff that's the one I want because my
Tick Tock I get banned all the time I'm
part of a a show called that show
tonight and we've been banned twice by
Tick Tock because we're critical of of
one of the
yes and my latest my latest video how to
escape your apartment when the doors
welded shut like
no views
yeah something's going on
yeah but I mean
digging the thing is is Tick Tock I
don't think is going to be going
anywhere I don't think they could if
they could ever actually ban it I mean
like the teens would be so upset
I I call my brother about this and I was
going to make a joke about it's only
teenagers and it's just you know and
he's like no and he got really angry
with me he was like no they're very
serious political discussions and shows
happening I was like okay but I thought
he was talking about like hobo talk oh
God like he was on the wrong fight you
know who said that coming back there's
everything they have uh the oddly
satisfying videos ones where they just
take out somebody's ear wax
them I feel like a kayaker right before
a whale breaches you're like wow that
came out of that time there are two
kinds of people there are people who
love watching pimples popped and ear wax
removal and then there are people who
are absolutely sickened by it and we'll
leave the room I don't like to watch it
but I like to do it
like I like to like like my husband
won't let me squeeze his blackheads what
it's I I thought you guys were in love
that's what I said I'm like you don't
want me to do you want me to go out
there and squeeze another man's
blackheads great point because if I'm
not getting it at home I'll get it
somewhere else
if you let me videotape it we can start
a channel yeah he also watches a lot of
tick-tock and he pretends he doesn't
like he's like you know that one dance
he's like he's like I don't know I'm
like well you just did the whole thing
so like I feel like you do actually know
the whole thing
let me pop his blackheads there might be
money in that for you I know I anyone
watching wants to come let me come to
your house and squeeze your blackheads
okay wait a second okay uh I just got
hit with the greatest money-making idea
okay like you're gonna be a billionaire
oh yeah next week
pop blackheads with your feet oh yes
with my feet all right very weird only
fans wait wearing Hosiery wearing Hosier
oh yeah I'm you guys will not see me on
Monday
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else